[Musik]
hey lieben heute machen wir einen objekt
orte und zwar eine total zitronige die
vorwürfe sich jetzt schon also ich
glaube die werde ich immer und immer
wieder machen und ihr genauso die torte
geht's super schnell wir machen jetzt
zuallererst ein no bnq boden und dafür
habe ich hier schon mal meine
butterkekse die werde ich fein mixen und
danach geschmolzene butter hinzufügen
[Musik]
und jetzt finden wir den keks boden noch
auf es gibt keine zitronen torte und
daher benutze ich heute ganz vielen
köpfen schäfers das habe ich eigentlich
immer im vorratsschrank weil ich backe
damit gerne ich spiele mir das aber auch
gerne zum frühstück aufs pro dass conti
vielseitig verwenden und da gebe ich
jetzt zwei teelöffel in die butterkeks
masse und die ganz genauen mengenangaben
die findet ihr wie immer hier unten in
der video beschreibung
[Musik]
und mit dem butterkeks boden ziehen wir
dann ein rand hoch und drücken alles
schön fest an
ich zum beispiel indem dafür am liebsten
meinen silikon koch helfer damit
funktioniert das total einfach und jetzt
gebe ich das hier erst einmal an die
seite und machen weiter mit der sahne
die sage kommt ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank gerade im sommer müsst ihr
darauf achten dass sie gekühlt ist ich
habe auch meine schlüssel um ein
schneebesen außer 25 minuten in die
kühlung getan und dann kann euch nichts
mehr schief gehen so das gebe ich jetzt
mit rein
natürlich könnt ihr auch eure handschuhe
gerät verwenden falls ihr keine
küchenmaschine habe so und ich werde das
ganze noch mit sahne fest ein bisschen
besser steifen und gerade im sommer auf
seine fest auch nicht unbedingt
verzichten
[Musik]
so die saale ist steif geschlagen und
jetzt habe ich hier noch magerquark ich
finde das passt perfekt zur zitronen
torte
das passt zum leben gehört und die creme
ist einfach ein schöner süchtig mache so
da gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen zucker
mit dazu ein bisschen vanille extrakt
weil ich finde auch dass vanille und
zitrone immer mega miteinander
harmonieren so und natürlich unser leben
könnte so von der fertigen kremls fünf
esslöffel zur seite legen das nutzen wir
den ich später noch für die deko und
jetzt geht es weiter mit mandarin ich
habe überlegt damit der anschnitt auch
aufregend ist nehmen wir uns jetzt
mandarin aus der dose die sind ja schon
geschehen
und die gebe ich jetzt einfach auf den
boden wichtig ist dass ihr die gut
abtropfen ist und dass ihr den saft aus
der dose schlichtweg schüttet
[Musik]
sagt dem mir dann die creme eingeführt
und glatt gestrichen habt hier nochmal
den rand säubern damit gleich wenn der
gust rüberkommt sich das nicht
miteinander vermischt so ihr lieben
jetzt geht es schon an den hübschen guss
ich sagt hübsch teil der ghost wird
richtig schön gelb sein und nach zitrone
schreien
ich habe jetzt hier den aufgefangene
saft von den mandarinen den gebe ich
hier in meinem kopf der herd ist noch
aus noch nicht einschalten so dann geben
wir da auch lähmen könnte dazu natürlich
für den geschmack und ihr müsst jetzt
nicht zusätzlich gelb färben denn durch
die hübsche farbe hier 40 gleicht das
ganze richtig schön gelb so und dann
ganz ganz wichtig brauchen wir aber das
ist pflanzt sich ist schlimm mittel ist
nun super alternative zur gelatine gebe
ich jetzt noch mit rein verrührt das
ganze und dann koche ich das auf und las
er dass zwei minuten lang schild
sprudelnd kochen
[Musik]
sonst habe ich den guss zehn minuten
lang abkühlen lassen damit er auch nicht
ganz so heiß auf die oberfläche kommt
jetzt schnappt ihr euch ein löffel und
dies ist ganz vorsichtig oben drüber
[Musik]
und nun muss die torte gekühlt werden
für mindestens drei stunden ihr könnt
das ganze auch über nacht vorbereiten
und dann habt ihr als am vortag ein
bisschen arbeit und könnte am nächsten
tag die leckere torte genießen so und
jetzt werde ich den tortenring entfernen
dafür am besten eine backform löser
nehmen damit ihr sie jetzt auch nicht
zerstört dass wir nämlich mega mega
schade und dann dekoriere ich noch mit
der restlichen sahne mit zitronen und
natürlich mit ein bisschen münze
[Musik]
die machen sich gesehen noch mal machen
hab ich nicht gesehen ich war ich
begeistert weil ich wollte es genau so
dass man auch so ein bisschen die creme
sieht und daneben der gelbe abschluss so
und jetzt bekomme ich fleißig
[Musik]
da fertig ist die wunderschöne und
erfrischenden lemon curt ort und das
ganze ohne backen und ohne viel aufwand
wie ich finde ich schreibe euch wie
gesagt alle ganz genauen mengenangaben
hier unten in die video beschreibung
ansonsten könnt ihr jetzt natürlich das
glas entweder auslöffeln aufs brot
schmieren oder was auch ganz cool ist
für den sommer ihr könnt daraus
eiswürfel machen gibt einfach noch ein
bisschen münster dazu frische früchte
das ganze dann zu als dürfen verarbeiten
und schon habt ihr das passende getränk
dazu wie genial ist das denn bitte ihr
euch ja von ganz viel freude beim
nachmachen abonniert main kanal komplett
kostenlos damit ihr solch genialen
rezeptoren nicht mehr verpasst und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder
auf die gis kitchen jeans
[Musik]